[Music]
this morning on a special edition of the
dish you may know jet Tila from his
appearances an Iron Chef chopped and
cutthroat kitchen
but in Los Angeles he's famous for a
different reason
his family open was thought to be the
first tygo Surrey store in the US we
visited Thai town with Tila to discuss
how he's keeping his family's legacy
alive there's a good landmark right like
you know you're in the heart of tight
own you can't visit la Thai town without
hitting a few of chef jet Tila favourite
haunts so we're gonna eat a run pair
this room this is the first stop of the
Thai town to her all the time I got
where his heritage is showcased through
culture and cuisine what I'll do is I'll
basically like curate the perfect bites
a little cashew chicken a little piece
of cashew a little rice it gets all
pushed into the to the spoon then you
clean off the bite to make sure you eat
and this is how you take a bite and
that's how a Thai person should be very
efficient Tila put Thai town on the map
when he brought a guy most people
recognized as knowing his way around the
international food scene I told these
businesses and in suppo 6 I was like I'm
bringing this guy named Anthony Bourdain
and then you might get busy and then we
blew these places out
there's good that interview with the
late Anthony Bourdain added to Tila's
already growing reputation I'm going to
do English muffin poached eggs which
ignited on cable TV the dressing is dish
sausage but to understand Tila you have
to go back to his Chinese and Thai
immigrant roots your family laid the
groundwork for Thai food and America
it's kind of a big responsibility so in
1966 my mom and my father immigrated to
Los Angeles separately they met a Fears
later because it was just it was a
little outpost it was all the Thai
people that were coming and going were
based in East Hollywood right here in
Silver Lake
they opened a grocery store in 1972 that
fed a growing immigrant community this
really reminds me of the struggle that
my parents endured it it's not a sad
story but it's time to put it to bed so
my mom can kind of enjoy the rest of her
life
his family closed down that location
three months ago but it remains the
treasured example of success that built
a company and seven restaurants I have a
lot of memories of the store they're all
fun memories until you know I got into
my teenage years and I was just angry at
that point cuz I had no social life and
then once I had a driver's license I did
a dude I drove away as fast as I could
dropped out of school you know what I
mean is working odd jobs I went back to
my family you know begged him to work
and took over I was a manager of the
grocery store while I was there I had a
group of non ties you know that we're
always wanting to it like they just came
back to Thailand they wanted to cook
dishes always asking how do I make pad
thai how do I make curry how do I make
this and they're like why don't you just
do a cooking class it didn't take long
for those cooking classes to turn into
front page news in the Los Angeles Times
and that was it from that moment the
next few days I got hundreds and
hundreds of phone calls and that made me
realize there is a need for someone to
communicate not just write recipes but I
did these fun little inner
active cooking classes lo mein means
soft noodles in of nice really thick
gravy which basically I still do in Food
Network today so that was it that was
the moment that was like I can do this
for the rest of my life he would
eventually open his own restaurant in
Las Vegas and land a guest spot on Iron
Chef America
it's iron chef morimoto and I was asked
to battle Masaharu Morimoto toughest
iron chef has scared to death walked
into kitchen Stadium met Morimoto it was
one of those battles were like no one no
one knew me so they expected me just to
get pummeled it would make really good
TV
right get some ratings and where is
everyone
that would bring him full circle and
give him a platform to share his roots
so is it possible to cook Pad Thai like
non sweetened have you controlled the
flavors you can make it any way you want
so yeah these days it's all about
control but I figured we'd do a Chinese
dish because that's my real roots you
know what I mean grandparents coming
from China we're gonna do a dish called
dan dan noodles control on the job and
in his own kitchen I got to think about
making noodles for dinner you know what
I'm saying
and there's something else about chef
Tila oh my god this is so good it's good
right and it's fast
something in his DNA that just won't
stop him from sharing what he's learned
along the way something that's helped to
revitalize this old neighborhood of his
you see the face is changing you know
yeah yeah basically a younger
generations taken over the Oder it's a
one-of-a-kind food experience where you
learn about Thai culture what's good one
of our bestsellers actually is the Feng
Chi which is I want to say macaroon but
I hate saying then even though it's a
coconut cookie cool a little bit yeah
a little bit of crisp on the outside it
doesn't get much sweeter than this
girl's sticky rice with banana if you
like banana and coconut this is it well
that's why you got to come here oh my
gosh can I get a scoop of that green tea
ice cream of course